what time is it I'm p.m. that can't be
right the sky's blue this is what 9 p.m.
is like here welcome a happy midsummer
unbelievable let's our feast come on
it's like they're trying to make it
gross what they play the fool so we just
gonna ignore the bed it's a bear
[Music]
dude of all the things to let me sleep
through
[Music]
sounds fun
I told you that I want to go to that
festival in Sweden no you said it would
be cool to go yeah and then I got the
opportunity and I decided to do it you
going I just wish he would have told me
that's all
dude she needs a therapist you've been
wanting out of this stupid relationship
for like a year now and don't forget
about all of the beautiful Swedish women
you'll need in June ok guys that's not
her again seriously babe what's
happening then
I was so very sorry to hear about what
happened I was really I invited Danny
may come this week you know what she's
been going Christian says you've got
this special week planned it's sort of a
crazy festival special ceremonies and
dressing up sounds fun
[Music]
unbelievable welcome and happy midsummer
school what time is it
I'm p.m. that can't be right the skies
blue this is 1 9 p.m. is like here
how long have you two been together just
over three and a half years four years
really yeah what do you think it's like
another world tomorrow's a big day is it
scary what is it it has special
properties what am I going through
we just need to acclimate I don't want
to acclimate I want to go
absolutely not what is happening
that's why you look so guilty right now
because you know
we only do this every 90 years
I was most excited for you to come
you